wang wade au dirigeant gouvernement
intérimaire depuis son bureau de
président de l'assemblée nationale après
l'appui massif des européens il en
attend un autre de la part du groupe de
lima l'espère est restée des deux
groupes au délit manqué star avec 0
à la clé si l'annoncé encore un appel à
l'armée pour encourager les défections
ce qui se fait progressivement l'aide
humanitaire qui doit remédier aux graves
pénuries du pays sont prêtes à la
frontière mais nicolás maduro se refuse
à reconnaître la crise
alors faut-il laisser entrer cette aide
d
l'objectif ultime c'est d'organiser des
élections donc nicolás maduro doit
quitter le pouvoir mais s'il le fait que
lui arrivera t'il à koloma gloser
quelques heures nous a permis titre kesa
ce n'est pas seulement parce que reina
mais la conditionnait bauer média et est
arrivé à part une fois jean michel
leprince ray du canada carcasse